this planet is still going to blow the
core has been completely disintegrated
by myth that's how long and thus began
the biggest lie in TV history
hello Internet
welcome to film theory we're ten
episodes three hours and thousands of
power levels later Namek finally
exploded the arms of the angel so let me
come out and say it
Dragonball Rox the characters the
villains but especially the powers I
mean what self-respecting kid hasn't
pretended to harness their ki and shoot
out giant energy balls or fly around
punching faster than the speed of light
or stood there screaming for hours
working to power up hey here's a joke
for you how many sands does it take to
screw in a light bulb one but it'll take
three episodes to do it bana net-net
banana banana Nana Nana now if there's
one attack that everyone associates with
the series it's Goku's famous Kamehameha
wave or turtle devastation wave named
after the Hawaiian King Kamehameha the
move is used by everyone from Master
Roshi to boo and as such comes with a
bunch of variations but more often than
not it consists of the character
gathering key energy between their hands
to form an energy ball that then gets
blasted out in a beam towards your big
bad with questionable gender hashtag
love wins and I have to say since
starting game theory four years ago I
have received so many emails tweets
Facebook messages from you loyal
theorists asking me to look into the
physics of this attack to figure out how
you can start blasting your best friend
into your neighbor's backyard and it was
tough I mean really tough actually as
what I found forced me to question some
of my basic assumptions about how the
universe works and that's no joke as
there were a lot of revelations during
the research for this one but I think
we've developed a pretty good theory
about what's going on during these moves
so let's start with what we're given by
the show in the series all these attacks
are based on key energy lifeforce energy
that exists inside every living being
with the major focus being in the center
of the body by drawing it out the user
is able to manipulate it and use it
outside the body from forming protective
key barriers to creating key balls and
key blasts to vaporize an opponent until
inevitably one
of him manages to survive and he's able
to completely regenerate even stronger
than before here have a sense ooh beam
while you're at it cuz that makes a lot
of sense
Super Saiyan more like stupid saying
stupid Senzu beans oh all the world's
existence hangs in the balance I want a
fair fight anyway I would think that
I'll come as no surprise to anyone to
hear that Dragon Balls key is a direct
reference to the real-life idea of T or
Chi one of the foundational principles
in Chinese medicines and martial arts
the word literally translates as breath
air or gas and it's thought to be a life
force or energy that exists in
everything just like it is in the show
in Hindu there's also the concept of
chakras centres of spiritual power
throughout the body so Chi and real life
is a hard to define mental or spiritual
energy that when mastered can heal the
wounded strengthen a fighter even go so
far as to give them Darth Vader force
light powers similar to what we're
seeing in the show at least that's what
some people believe but there's one big
problem here there's no good sources
backing any of this up whether you
believe in Chi energy or not most of the
quote-unquote science conducted
supporting Chi was done by people with a
firm belief in holistic medicine so
definitely not the most impartial of
judges and neutral researchers well
they're just not interested in testing
videos of people rolling around like
idiots
or should I say more importantly the
people with grant dollars aren't
interested in funding that sort of
research which means no scientists care
so that's a bummer but of course we're
not gonna leave it at that I am NOT
going to let the scientific community's
inability to test this stuff prevent me
from shooting energy beams of light out
of my hands I mean if Crillon can do it
so can i dammit and as an aside here can
I just say how depressing it is to think
that Crillon is one of the strongest
human beings alive on that show oh
that's a sobering thought anyway we're
gonna step in where science has failed
and answer the true question these top
research institutions should be looking
at how does a fictional character shoot
a fictional wave of energy out of his
hands
well to truly understand what's going on
we have to look at the waves properties
and the first thing to note is
that this isn't just an energy wave you
can't see energy energy is a property of
a physical thing something physical has
to possess that energy if you need proof
from the show look at Gohan's Kamehameha
wave pushing against cells near the end
of that story arc see how his ball of
energy causes cells to collapse in on
itself and response it's like if I
pushed on a piece of cellophane or
Reynolds Wrap clearly there's a lot of
energy there but it's being carried in a
physical form it is literally a form of
matter what's the matter I don't know
what's the matter with you aah ooh bad
marks jokes aside matter is anything
that takes up space and has mass I'm
sure we've all learned the three states
of matter right solids liquids gases
problem is the Kamehameha wave doesn't
behave like any of those so what is it
well I hate to break it to you but your
3rd grade science teacher has been a
part of a lifelong conspiracy a cover-up
misleading generations of young students
there aren't just three states of matter
there's actually 4th plasma and it's
this fourth state of matter that unlocks
all the secrets to Dragon Balls energy
blasts in fact let me tell you how big
this lie you've been told actually is
solids liquids and gases make up one
percent of the universe one measly
percent matter in a state of plasma
makes up the other 99% of the observable
universe which makes humans quite
literally part of the one percent
so stop occupying Wall Street you
hippies so why of elementary school
science teachers hidden this fact from
generations of kids well third grade is
pretty early to be learning physical
chemistry plus plasma isn't something
that we run into all that often on earth
you're probably most familiar with it
thanks to fluorescent light bulbs what's
lighting up in their plasma lightning
also plasma stars like our Sun we've all
been led to believe that there are big
balls of gas even by NASA in an
incredibly poorly written definition on
their website well that's wrong they're
mostly plasma because of how
they are and by the way NASA change that
please you can't say it's mostly a ball
of gas but then say it's mostly plasma
they are two different states of matter
it'd be like me saying this turkey
sandwich is a ham sandwich just because
it has another meat knit they're close
but they're not the same can you tell
that I skipped lunch to write this
episode so before we see how plasma
plays a part in Dragon Ball we need to
know what exactly it is you know when
you heat up a solid it melts and becomes
a liquid and you heat it up a bit more
and it becomes a gas well if you heat
the gas even more it becomes plasma
basically the electrons and the atoms of
the gas gets so excited they start to
break away so what you end up with is
the soup of negatively charged electrons
floating alongside positively charged
ions from the atoms that have lost their
electrons long story short the main
thing to remember is a plasma is a
superheated gas so when goku makes a
ball of energy appear out of nothing
that's not 100% true there's gas air
between his hands that he's super
heating to create that ball so the next
logical question there is how is he
heating it up and the answer is
surprisingly simple just like a
fluorescent bulb when you turn on a
light electricity is sent through the
gas in the tube super charging the atoms
so that the electrons start popping off
creating the glowing plasma to
illuminate the room the characters and
dragonball are doing the same thing
their key power is really them
harnessing their body's electric
potential and focusing it on areas
around them skeptical I hear what you're
saying but consider this in the battle
against Vegeta Goku calls upon his
triple Kaioken attack and what do we see
happen electricity starts radiating
around his body his electric potential
has skyrocketed and a super sands ascend
to higher and higher levels we see
lightning pulsing around their bodies
lightning aka plasma but that's not all
you know how any of these Warriors need
a huge burst of energy to ascend to the
next level or start their energy attack
but then once they're there they're able
to sustain that power level
well plasma and electric potentials
explain that too to convert any
asked to plasma including air there's a
big start of energy typically around 33
kilovolts per centimeter
but once the plasma arcs been created it
can be sustained with only a tenth of
that energy three kilovolts per
centimeter by that same principle the
arc needs to be started next to its
energy source but once there it can be
drawn out to ten times the distance from
said source wage in the case of the
Kamehameha wave is why the wave starts
near Goku and then can a reach out so
far away from him and B is so much
stronger when launched near the opponent
like when Goku chose to fire at
point-blank at cell as his last-ditch
attempt to finish the fight speaking of
villains during the second coming of
broli we see that Kamehameha's can
combine to become even stronger as Gohan
Goten and Goku join forces for the
so-called family Kamehameha it would be
a touching moment if I weren't so
distracted by the fact that Goku is
literally a spirit in this instance if
you'll pardon my little rant here but I
mean okay the guy dies and his wish back
into existence every 10 episodes
fine I accept that but for his attack to
be viable when he's still technically a
ghost ah anyway the important point here
is that the separate beams can combine
and grow stronger plasma exhibits this
same quality look at your typical plasma
ball no that's not just an outdated desk
ornament it's a lesson on Dragon Ball Z
physics notice that as the beams of
plasma have a point to focus on they
combine and grow stronger bigger and
more powerful just like we see on the
show and don't worry I hear your
question if plasma is just a superheated
gas how can it obliterate sell or push
people away PS Goku should've won death
battle hashtag butthurt well listen up
salty Superman hater because that's
probably the single biggest clue that
these beams are plasma instead of just
pure energy you see the wild thing about
plasma is that they're nothing like a
gas that's why they qualify as an
entirely separate state of matter
remember that this is the stuff that
stars are made of so Goku is basically
creating a
small star in between his hands and at
high temperatures plasma becomes thicker
more viscous to the level that it can
physically be pushed that's why everyone
from Frieza Daboo can try to stop these
things with their hands it's also how in
that earlier example Gohan's wave is
able to push cells back into the sky
it's a denser plasma beam able to
overcome the momentum of his attack it's
also how Goku is able to form a key
shield it's the same plasma shield
technology that the company Boeing has
just patented I kid you not
plasma shields are becoming a real thing
truly we live in the future and you know
how characters are always getting into
energy clashes with the two beams
struggling for superiority
whether it's go han versus el or Goku
versus Vegeta beams colliding is a
staple of the show with that rounded
ball shape being iconic of these sorts
of standoffs would one plasma beam be
able to push against another well yes in
real life it's difficult to find
examples that are nearly that
spectacular or focused but putting two
plasma balls together and watching their
beams strike each other you see them
pushing against one another forcing into
each other up and out until the
connection is broken or they're too far
away from their primary energy source
and then what about that ball shape well
we can compare the beam collision to
that of stars in outer space looking at
their collision patterns when two big
balls of plasma combine at moderate high
speeds they splash outward like we see
in the goku vegeta battle but they also
fuse together huge into a swirling mass
of energy their magnetic fields
reorganize into a ball shape before well
in space they create a black hole in
Dragon Ball it doesn't go that far oh
sure the planet will most likely come to
a horrific conclusion but you know at
least we won't be crushed under the
infinite blackness of gravity so there
you have it key and wave attacks are
most likely electric potentials and
plasma it's interesting in the end
spiritual energies like Dragon Balls key
or real-life Qi are models created to
explain weird trend
our natural phenomenon the world around
us in that they're not that far
different from a scientific theory
theories by their nature are incomplete
and you know what probably wrong in some
ways sometimes in a lot of ways but what
they provide is a useful explanation for
what we see until we inevitably learn
more and revise our theories to
accommodate that new information in this
case plasma and electric potentials work
fairly well for a phenomenon we see
throughout the series evolve change by
its own logic
sorry just theorizing about theorizing I
guess I should end on a joke now um oh I
know Dragon Ball GT but I'm Ching but
hey that's just a theory a film theory
and cut if I could summon Shenron right
now I'd wish that you'd subscribe so
make my wish come true spirit bomb that
button or maybe I can make your wish for
another Dragonball video come true click
right here to check out my 1-minute lore
episode covering the back story of the
franchise who cares if you know it
already the animations are awesome and
I'm there too which should count for
something and with Dragon Ball super
going on might as well refresh yourself
with good old mat paths and Yamcha
actually Yamcha is not there finally for
you people who refuse to click on
anything do you like five nights at
Freddy's if so there's a brand new
theory today click the purple fanned
whole to find out the huge mistake Scott
made and snap four seriously Scott you
screwed the pooch on this one now if
you'll excuse me I've got something a
bit more joyful to do some research on